الى محيط بلده افديك حيث المعارك الضاريه
نرافق هذا المسعف الاوكراني الذي يخاطر
بحياته لانقاذ امراه مسنه عالقه في
المنطقه التي يحاصرها الجنود الروس من كل
الجهات بفضل هذا الطقس العاصف سيكون كل
شيء على ما يرم اعتقد اننا سننجح في تجنب
الصواريخ لكن عندما تكون السماء صافيه
يزداد الوضع خطوره لكن عند وصولنا لم نجد
اثرا للمراه
المسنه سيدتي سيدتي
مع اجداد القصف كان من المستحيل البقاء
هنا اذا نشد المسعف مجموعه من الجنود
لتقديم المساعده نحن على بعد كيلومترين من
خط المواجهه اليس كذلك كلا نحن الان على
خط المواجهه في الجهه المقابله من البلده
عثرنا على ليديا وزوجها مع السلامه كنا
نعيش هنا رغم ان نصف منزلنا دمر بالكامل
زوجي لن يرافقني سيبقى ليهتم بالمشيه وانا
ساغادر
وحيده و وحسره ومخاوف من ان تكون هذه
المره الاخيره التي ترى فيها زوجها لان
الروس يحرزون تقدما يوما بعد يوم في
المنطقه التي ما يزال يقطنها مئات
الاوكرانيين يواجه الجنود الاوكرانيين
قوات العدو بالاسلحه السوفيتيه القديمه
وهذه المعدات المحليه الصنع التي
يستخدمونها للمره الاولى لذا اجبرنا
الجنود على الابتعاد خشيه من ان تنفجر في
ظل ظروف قتاليه صعبه يتساءل هؤلاء الرجال
ما فكانت اديف كا ستنجح في الصمود اذا تم
امدادنا بالاسلحه الحديثه بالطبع سنتمكن
من تحرير افديك لكن اذا تمروا البلده كما
فعلوا في بخم لن يكون هناك حاجه للبقاء
هنا ولا للتضحيه بالمزيد من الارواح
الخسائر البشريه تبدو كبيره من كلا
الطرفين والارهاق يبدو واضحا على الوجوه
ورغم ذلك يجتمعون يوميا للصلاه والحصول
على قسط من الراحه قبل التوجه مجددا الى
جبهه القتال
[موسيقى]
be